I'm going to give you a list and you
tell me what doesn't fit the list Queens
Brighton Beach the Bronx Brooklyn Lower
East Side the Amazon you would have to
ask Brad Pitt at that same question
because I have no idea that's how this
all started was it's a very strange
sentence really but it's true I was I
was at home and the phone rang and it
went something like this
hello hey Jimmy Jam
it's Brad Pitt bpe got this book pan I
just bought this book for me called lost
cities he want you to do it Jimmy Jam
what do you think
hello and the next thing I knew I got
this thing in the mail and I read it I
have I had never been as you correctly
say I'd never been west of the East
River
I have no idea what why they thought of
me to do it and my first instinct when I
read it was that it was a terrific book
totally unmake about and I should just
you know pass but then these things work
out you know I started to get obsessed
you know but it was really one passage
in the book a very short thing in the
book which you have read you'll know or
maybe you won't dive so small which was
about his dad being a mess basically I
mean his father was a curry to Edward
the seventh he chose his ancestors
poorly yes and he was a drunk and a
gambler it destroyed not one but two
family fortunes which I don't really see
how that's possible but he managed and
he had destroyed the family name so
Fawcett was compelled to sort of make up
for that and I thought well that's great
the rest of this thing I can't do but
that's great
thousand years later here right there
you are so I know what happens is you
know I have an obsessive problem myself
much like mr. faucitt and I became
really interested I started reading
these other things about the Amazon that
came across and again thought I could
never do it and then
finally one thing led to another I found
myself saying okay I'll just write the
script and then I wrote the script and I
gave it to my friend who's a super-duper
famous director much more successful
than I and and I love him dearly I went
to film school with him the norm for 30
years and I said to him what do you
think of the script and he always is
very honest with me so I like giving him
my stuff and he said yeah why do you
want do this so what do you miss that
bad it's not oh no I liked the script at
times not doing anything so what were
you doing you have the Amazon you do
that thing then you get World War one
you mean the trench with the mud you do
that you can do that I think you can do
that and he was sort of right because I
God but I did do it and then I was not
going to direct it and then I say I so
they said okay we're gonna go on a scout
to Brazil I saw I'll do that that sounds
interesting and so then I found myself
in Brazil on the scout when you look at
David Graham's book there are many ways
that you can go there is the story of
the explorations there were eight you
focus on three there are the countless
countless rescue attempts I mean there
was a rescue attempt I think in 1928
where 20,000 people applied to be part
of it and then there's the author's own
quest to try to replicate some of
Percy's travels that's right so there's
three different books or three different
stories within the book that's right you
discard stories two and three to focus
on the former well I'm a movie nerd and
if you're a movie nerds you know that a
lot of great movies have been based on
short stories you know rear-window
Cornell Woolrich right the short stories
can to provide it because movies are
like they're almost like it's almost
like a bullet you know not a TV show
which can go on forever the movie has
basically one idea to it and even
something that has heavily adapted a lot
of story removed sometimes has to be
three hours to accommodate the story
like The Godfather or something so I
knew instantly that there was too much
story and the part of the story that I
got rid of first was David gran
wandering around the jungle because
that's like me wandering the jungle and
that is not interesting you do not want
to see
but also it that had been done already
that kind of postmodern like I'm gonna
look at this ironically where he's like
in the jungle but I'm gonna be in the
jungle too and I'm gonna have this whole
thing it's been done brilliantly well
it's called adaptation
I'm not going to redo spikes movie I'm
only going to look like a pale and and
it's so then I thought well what's old
is new you know can I do a movie in this
file of David Lean with a kind of
updated 20 at the time 2015 politics and
I thought well that's interesting
because not all people doing that and
then you have to get rid of if you're
going to do that then you have to get
rid of the whole story after he
disappeared and so then all of a sudden
I don't say write itself it doesn't then
you know but but that's not what the way
it works but then the story does become
a bit more manageable and eight eight
eight trips into three was a for me than
me maybe I'm wrong was an easy decision
because the three acts in a movie right
and his eight trips there was several
trips where he went with a lot of guys
just like mr. Murray which turned out to
be catastrophic so I mean how many times
you can watch a catastrophic journey
when you were thinking about making this
movie the natural people that I think a
lot of filmmakers would call would be
Verner Herzog and Francis Ford Coppola
well that's a big it's a big issue you
raise so I'm three I'm raising it
because I let me just say right up front
that Apocalypse Now is one of my
favorite movies of all time he is my
hero Francis Coppola and I love their
inner hearts like I love the gate I love
Fitzcarraldo but it represented a major
challenge for me because I didn't want
to do those movies I felt that the story
was very very different and we can talk
about the major difference I'm just
thinking about how to shoot in the
jungle no waiting about but reckon that
this is connected entirely to the shoot
really you know the way that somehow the
form sometimes dictates the content we
did not look at those movies at all
because I felt that you know agita is
not a racist movie because he becomes
insane due to his megalomania his own
megalomania and his own avarice right he
wants to find the city of gold and goes
berserk and there's monkeys all over his
raft
whatever but this story is a person who
makes a connection with the indigenous
people and it's not about a search for
gold and some crazed and so I felt that
if I had shown him going crazier and
crazier and crazier then it would have
been kind of in a weird way racist
because it would have meant that his
confrontation with the indigenous
peoples of South America made him go
nuts which is it that [ __ ] and as a
result I knew that I mean maybe that's
wrong maybe it would be more cool to
have him go around on the end of the
movie but I honestly think that that is
a very dangerous thing to do because a
it's not true if anything drove the real
force of crazy
it was the war it was life in the
trenches and the other thing that I felt
was that the form of the movie had to
take on a more poetic feel as
particularly as it went on and that it
couldn't be I walked down to the jungle
and I went crazy and I had all these
equipment you know like that that it had
to have a more controlled sense because
it wasn't about the same thing and the
one thing that connected this to Verena
Hertzog's masterpieces and Francis
Coppola masterpiece was merely the
setting of the jungle but that's not
really what the story is James Gray
thank you so much thank you thank you
guys for coming